repos forcé pour ses vaches et leur
broutards en temps normal toutes ces
bêtes seraient en partance pour l'italie
ou la turquie
mais depuis hier et la découverte d'un
cas de fc au fièvre catarrhale ovine
dans l'allier elles sont immobilisés sur
l'exploitation
car pour éviter la propagation de cette
maladie les éleveurs du cher ont
interdiction de déplacer leurs bêtes et
donc de les vendre
c'est normal on sait quand on vend les
animaux au début octobre c'est pour
payer des échéances qui sont calés cette
période là donc ça implique d'aller voir
la démo le banquier ça implique d'aller
voir tous les tous les clients du
fournisseur et puis rorschach le point
et on est un peu désespéré comme
désespérée de temps qu'il faut conclut
mourir tous ces animaux et avec la
sécheresse de l'été le fourrage se fait
rare et les dépenses se multiplient une
très mauvaise nouvelle qui fait suite à
un été compliqué avec des cours du prix
de la viande en baisse et une forte
concurrence européenne laurent charrier
le sait ces bovins ont peu de chances
d'intéresser les acheteurs à un bon prix
après cette crise sanitaire le temps que
protocole de vaccination se mettent en
place
si on compte deux mois et demi trois
mois et en les aurons encore dans les
bâtiments dans les stabulations au
moment où va falloir rentrer les vaches
pour les prochains village et donc le
bal à stabulation sont pas extensibles
déjà que l'on manque de nourriture est
donc certain moment là la crainte
principale c est obligé de les brader
tragique pour l'élevage la fièvre
catarrhale ovine était déjà apparu en
france en 2007 et avait causé fausse
couche et problèmes de stérilité dans le
cheptel français une maladie transmise
par un moucheron sans conséquence pour
l'homme cette maladie est une maladie
animale est strictement animal elle a
aucun impact en matière de santé humaine
d'autre part donc pas transmissible à
l'homme et d'autre part elle ne présente
aujourd'hui aucun risque pour le
consommateur et à aucune des denrées
découlant de la consommation des animaux
c'est à dire la viande le lait ne
présentent un risque quelconque
jours pour contenir cette maladie des
contrôles vétérinaires et des
vaccinations vont être mises en place
dans les exploitations situées dans un
rayon de 150 km autour du foyer
infectieux